strange as it may seem the very first
academy awards did not include a
category for best supporting actress
it's our good fortune and that of these
five wonderful first-time nominees
that the good old days have gotten
better
the nominees for best actress in the
supporting role are
joan allen in nixon
kathleen quinlan in apollo 13.
mira servino in mighty aphrodite
mayor whittingham in georgia
and kate winslet
in sense and sensibility
and the oscar is presented to
miris sorvino in mighty aphrodite
oh my god um
thank you very much to all the members
of the academy um thank you very much to
woody allen for
writing this beautiful character
and for seeing fit to cast me in it and
doing such a beautiful film um
i i want to thank my agents michelle
stern frank frederolli and steve himber
at william morris and also very special
thanks to larry taub my manager gene fox
who i love very dearly
all of my friends who you know who you
are and i love you very much and my
parents and my family and when you give
me this award you honor my father paul
cervino who has taught me everything i
know about acting
i love you very much dad
i
i i always looked
at great performances and was so moved
by how much other people's hearts made
me feel
as a child and
i wanted to be an actor who could move
other people and make other people see
something about the human spirit and
you've made me feel that i've made a
small step towards that so thank you
very much everybody thank you